cargos de homicidio involuntario les han
sido imputados a los padres de it and
from play el adolescente acusado de
asesinar a cuatro estudiantes y herir a
otras siete personas en la escuela
secundaria de michigan donde asistía
tras abrir fuego el 30 de noviembre
una investigación adicional reveló que
la pistola sig sauer de 9 milímetros
comprada por james gran ley estaba
guardada sin llave en un cajón del
dormitorio de james y jennifer la
pistola recuperada del tirador en la
escuela después del tiroteo
era la misma que fue comprada por su
padre james crowley el 26 de noviembre
de 2021 en presencia de su hijo en
fancesa según las investigaciones de la
fiscalía jennifer y james crowley le
habrían comprado el arma como regalo de
navidad a ethan cuatro días antes del
tiroteo y tan mostró fotos de la pistola
en las redes sociales su madre publicó
al día siguiente que los dos estaban
probando su regalo de navidad anticipado
el 21 de noviembre un maestro vio a la
adolescente buscando municiones en su
teléfono durante la clase y alertó a los
funcionarios de la escuela quienes
dejaron mensajes de voz para su que no
fueron contestados en la mañana del
tiroteo un maestro descubrió un dibujo
que y tan tranvía había hecho con una
pistola una bala y una silueta humana
sangrando días después del tiroteo la
comunidad no sale del asombro teseida en
decir que todavía estoy en estado de
shock y entumecido es probablemente un
eufemismo aplaudiendo en el sistema
y tan ramli será procesado como adulto
pese a ser menor de edad sus padres
quienes -según la fiscalía- desestimaron
las señales de advertencia a la mañana
del incidente enfrentan cuatro cargos
cada uno que podrían traducirse en una
condena de 15 años de prisión de ser
hallados culpables